[Music]
oh
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud loud proud proud and do not
give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
him can you smell the [__] in Grandpa's
diaper
what an [__] I want to be dictator
I'm not going to leave no matter
what I mean these are this is [__] we
already knew right like it's not
complicated to understand that he's a
[__] petulent child and then he would
just you know you know what you know
what I'm talking about you go in a
grocery store and it might be your kid
it might be someone else's kid I don't
know maybe I'm making fun of the
audience here but you know this is how
it works
you go on the GS store and you
see a family with some kids and one of
the kids little kid looks like Dennis
the Menace you know what I'm talking
about just a [__] ass you could tell
that kid's an [__] you know what I
mean I mean you know he's a kid but he's
a [__] [__] won't shut up won't
quit whining wants everything in the
grocery store his parents can barely
afford to buy the [__] they got in the
cart and he wants everything and then
when he do get he Blaze on the floor
crying stomping his feet I don't
want you just want to [__] stand him
up and say look here you little [__]
look here you little [__] you [__]
lost okay you [__]
lost Brandon W you crybaby little [__]
and all your all your [__] fans out
there that think you're cool throwing
this little fit here in the grocery
store in the cereal aisle because you
ain't getting your [__] way
ain't playing with the rest of us the
rest of us in this Gore hate your
[__]
ass and if you don't [__] if you
don't stop your little fit
throwing you might just get a spanking
on the ass you know what I mean that's
the way you it's the way you [__]
feel you know what I'm saying right deep
down in your core you just want to tell
that little [__] in the Cal you [__]
lost you little [__] you know you lost
everyone knows you lost even the people
are saying that you didn't lose and
defending you in court that you didn't
lose you [__] lost they know you
lost but on and on it goes cuz these
fascist don't give in they don't give in
that's why you shouldn't give
in oh
[__] I was right again speaking of
fascist speaking of white Christian
nationalist speaking of online
accountability
Partners Mike Johnson says he fully
supports Donald Trump he's all in his
head is all in his ass
he's all in on Trump his head is fully
up Donald Trump's
ass says that he's a trump man and also
trying to pass a CR this
afternoon Mike Johnson knows one thing
that if he bling brings a clean CR to
the floor the Democrats are going to
vote for it and the reason why is
because Democrats give a [__] about the
American people even if it's a dumb
[__] deal like the 45 days CR that
the last Speaker of the House passed
with Democrat
votes now I said this couple weeks ago
they're going to shut down the
government the Republicans are going to
shut down the government now I also said
that it is it is very likely that they
will pass the CR into January I can pull
the [__] clip if I need
to I said I told you this I went on a
[__] whole rant about how they
weren't going to shut down the G before
Thanksgiving because your farm fash
Facebook Uncle Fred would had his turkey
gulled by you if they shut down the
government because what would happen is
before the holidays people families
would get together all around the
country and blame Republicans for the
[__] shutdown during the
holidays it's not [__] complicated
it's not complicated [__] this easy [__]
to know so that's why Mike Johnson's
kicking it into January just like I
[__]
said Tony's right again and it's not
because I'm [__] all knowing or have
some kind of crystal ball I just have
the ability to try to [__] put myself
in these scumbag shoes and think about
what's the worst possible outcome that
these [__] [__] could do and
then do 10 times worse and that's what
they'll
do what a [__]
[__] what a [__] listen if I was
if I was to advise the Democrats right
now the house Democrats I would vote no
on this [__] [__] that [__] [__] them
punting it at another [__] 60 days
you [__] [__] you goddamn [__]
what the [__] are you doing kicking this
into January it's obvious what Mike
Johnson is doing Mike Johnson
understands now now that he's the
speaker that he can't he can't keep the
government open the only way that he's
goingon to convince Trump to keep the
government open is this holiday bit he's
like no no no no we we'll close it in
January I promise I promise dear leader
boss I guess as they call him can you
imagine having to [__] get on your
knees and kiss his ring and call him
boss get the [__] out of here with that
[__] I I don't work well for other
people like I don't work well for a boss
right it's just never something I've
done and the reason why is because of my
[__] mouth I have the I have the
innate unability
to [__] not say what I think I don't
know if you
noticed I just can't help it I gotta say
what the [__] I
think and it never works out well in a
workplace when you're challenging
someone who's a [__] idiot who has
power above you it doesn't work well so
I don't work well under a boss so that's
one reason why I probably hate his
[__] guts and I would never be able
to be one of these fascist is because I
would never genu flect and call someone
else boss are you [__] me get the
[__] out of here man how degrading but
they are [__] weak cowards and
they're snowflakes these fascists like
Jenna Ellis but Mike Johnson's the same
way I almost bet you I almost bet you in
Mike Johnson's cell phone his
accountability partner's name is boss
boss I mean and Trump's now his online
accountability partner can you imagine
trying to get the getting the porn from
the Christian I I trade you trade us
porn You Porn can you imagine trying to
get Donald Trump's porn oh
[__] oh it's probably horrible it's
probably just pictures of himself if you
want to know the honest truth I mean
what else would he be looking at anyways
I digress from that Mike Johnson's
kicking the can down the road into
January just like I said they would
because they don't want the American
people to be talking about how the
republ Republicans can't govern during
the
holidays they they just
don't they don't so they're going to
kick it into January and then shut down
the government
then it's what I said would
happen it's amazing and the Democrats
are going to pass this bill again
because Democrats are serious [__]
politicians some some days like today I
wish they weren't so serious and they
would tell them to [__] off yeah you're
not going to get our help to kick this
into January [__] you you you want to
shut down the government go ahead shut
down the government live with the
consequences
here but the Democrats are not going to
do that they're not going to do that
because it's the American people and
it's the holidays and they give a [__]
about the American working
class they do that's the difference
everyone's like yeah there's no
difference between the
parties yeah there
is yeah there is and it's and it's
you've seen it twice twice just in the
last couple [__] months where
Democrats save a republican
speaker from being blamed of a
government shutdown and voting with him
on a clean CR 45 days in Kevin
McCarthy's case only into January for
micro Johnson's
case that's where we're
at also where we're at speaking of trump
controlling Mike Mike Johnson because
that's what's happening Trump controls
the Republican Party Jenna Ellis drops a
bombshell in a leak tape yesterday of a
profer to Georgia prosecutors as part of
her plea deal into
Trump's kangaroo Cheeto dust kangaroo
coup
plot basically admitting that there was
White House
staff that was telling her now now this
is why it's so significant that Jenna
Ellis is the one that is saying this on
tape because a lot of right Wingers like
oh this is all
heay this didn't really happen this is
fake is it real or is it AI you know
they're doing that kind of
[__] they're questioning rather Jenna
Ellis is telling the truth well the the
problem that you have right Wingers is
she's doing a proper and these
prosecutors are going to
check they're going to check the
evidence that she's going to provide for
that and the problem that you have is in
a proper for her plea
deal if she [__] lies she will lose
her plea deal and she is not going to do
that you dumb
[__] that is why she's telling
us [__] that we already knew we already
knew that Donald Trump was gonna be a
[__] baby we already knew that Donald
Trump definitely was going to try to go
to any extent to stay in in in power and
then he wanted to be a dictator and the
king of the United States of
stupidity that's why he sent his [__]
toothless sheep to the capital to try to
hang Mike Pence and overthrow the
government because that was one of his
last ditch
efforts and even take think about this
think about this in context Jenna Ellis
is running around the country with Rudy
kudi right now you know Rudy's in on
this too this is why Rudy hasn't flipped
yet Rudy's probably number two or number
three man in this Rico scheme he's
completely [__] because now Jen Ellis
is is all but admitting that yes they
were trying to overthrow the election
and they were saying it out loud In The
West
Wing Dan scavino which is Trump was or
is I don't know he's still a [__]
Trump lacky why the [__] he isn't being
prosecuted I have no idea maybe he will
be in
DC but Dan scavino telling Jenna Ellis
In The West Wing they are not he is not
going to the boss the boss boss isn't
going to leave boss the [__] out of here
with that
[__] you know it's funny all these
[__] Hunter Biden lamptop trolls you
know what I'm talking about they're like
Hunter B's lamptop Hunter Biden Hunter
bid's laptop and then Hunter Biden gets
charged with Federal felonies and
they're like Hunter Hunter Biden's
laptop maybe may maybe
maybe you know those [__] that
are in your
comments yelling and screaming they're
like oh they called Joe Biden the big
guy the big guy the big guy Oh see it's
definitely crime when Joe Biden gets
called the big guy Donald Trump was
forcing these people to call him boss
folks do you see the [__] projection
here do you see do you see how it [__]
[__] works when you can't you can't
[__] take anything these people say
seriously honestly When Donald Trump
says
something when he says something I start
off thinking well then it's the exact
opposite whatever he's saying then it's
probably the [__] exact that's where
I
start I'm not saying that's the case
every single time but that's where I
start to digest what the [__] he's
talking about whatever word salad that
he's puking up at the moment
they were calling him
boss and he was saying I'm not gonna
leave I'm not gonna go no [__] way no
[__] how and Jenna Ellis is saying
this folks that she was in The West Wing
she was in the White House in the
[__] building where this [__]
was
at she wasn't getting a phone call from
this person to this person and this
person told this person and that person
said this no she's standing in the west
wing with his staff and his staff is
saying no he is not going to leave we
don't give a [__] what the consequences
are he's not going to leave that's why
he didn't show up at the inauguration
that's why he's a whiny little [__]
that's why to this day he still [__]
whines and complains and pisses and
moans it's probably why he stole the
documents in the first place oh you're
gonna kick me out of the White House and
not make me your dictator and your furer
well I'll just take this [__]
box it up [__] box up all I
want everything it's all mine I'm taking
the whole government with me we're gonna
make the White House Mar Lago couldn't
you see that [__] throwing ketchup
against the wall and [__] [__] people
Walt teen has to bring in diet oh sir
here's Diet Coke please calm down please
calm down boss
boss are you [__] kidding
me you act like I'm crazy and out of
control that is 100% what [__]
happened I wasn't even there I wasn't
even there you weren't there but we know
that's what the [__] happened we know he
he he lost his [__] mind and he was
the little kid in the grocery store
because he didn't get the [__] box of
cereal that he
wanted you're not making me the
dictator you rejected me you hate my
guts yeah we hate your [__] guts
we still ate your [__] guts we're
going to hate your guts next year too
[__] we're gonna pile mountains
of votes on top of you dumb sons of
[__] now the [__]
media oh my god oh boy it's gonna be too
bad and too bad and get the [__] out of
here
man the media is such [__] and then
this morning I watched the clip of
Jonathan Carl we me and Gabe Sanchez
talked about this a little bit Jonathan
Carl has a brand new book out and he
went on an MSNBC show with Jin saki I
used to have a little bit
of respect for her it kind of lost a
little bit I'm not gonna lie I'm not I'm
gonna say it I don't give a [__] this
[__] [__] where Jonathan Carl is
going on a book tour and talking about
an anonymous source in the White House
who said at the time that Trump was
doing what he was doing was a [__]
traitor and a malignant cancer on our
country but it's still an anonymous
source they won't tell us who the [__]
it is get the [__] out of here you
[__] cowards now a lot of people are
like oh but Tony but Tony they're
they're they're Expos get the [__] out
say who the [__] it is I don't give a
[__] what the legal consequences are I
don't give a [__] I don't care how many
books you're trying to sell I don't give
a [__] what kind of money you're trying
to get [__] you Jonathan Carl [__] you
and [__] you jinaki [__] you [__] anyone
who's having that son of a [__] on
talking about his goddamn book and his
Anonymous sources who are saying [__]
that the American people need to [__]
know so they can make a goddamn decision
it's [__] it's [__] [__] and
it's more of people like Jonathan Carl
thinking that they can [__] they can
manipulate us into thinking and voting
the way that they [__] want this is
why the media get
mock this is why the media [__] they're
not the Enemy of the State like the
[__] fascist state but they're dumb
as dog [__] to think that we aren't on
to them that I I'm not on to Jonathan
Carl sitting on jinaki show well an
anous Source who worked for Donald Trump
for a year oh but Tony you can do the
math and you can see who it is well
[__] then say it then you goddamn
[__] [__] say it I'm sick and
tired of you [__] out there
profiting off the demise of our [__]
democracy you pieces of [__] yeah I'm
talking to you Jonathan Carl I'm talking
to you jinaki I'm talking to you well
but oh they have an agreement of an
anonymous thing and he'll get sued
[__] sueing if it were me I'd say it
out loud I'd [__] say it right here
on this show you could [__] sue me do
it do it [__] let's go to court let's
go to court let's see how the American
people feel about you and me because I'm
saying [__] you [__]
said whoever the [__] this anonymous
source is so that Jonathan Carl can sell
his [__] book so you go buy his
[__] book what a what a bunch of
[__]
[__] I I I I I will not [__]
probably ever respect Jonathan Carl ever
again or anything that [__] says
or
writes he is not serious he's not a
serious [__] [__] agent of the press
he's not a serious [__] journalist
he's in it for profit and money only
yeah but Tony you got to make money he's
in business we're talking about our
[__] democracy here
folks Jonathan Carl will be one of the
first they put on the [__] train when
Trump takes takes over and wants to
[__] wants to [__] send people to
camps you kidding me and Jonathan Carl
[__] yucking it up with jinaki on
MSNBC talking about Anonymous sources in
his book say who the [__] it is tell us
tell us who the [__] it is have some
goddamn
guts grow some [__] balls and tell us
quit being such [__] cowards and
trying to hide behind it and sell
books the [__] out of here with this
[__] we watch these other fascists
do the same thing that Jonathan Carl's
doing bill bar did it Mike Pence did it
they're all going to [__] do
it [__] how do you think I I know a lot
of people are going to hate me for this
how do you think cidy Hutchinson pay for
her [__] attorney how do you think
she walked away from the Trump attorney
because of her book
deal this is dumb [__] man this is dumb
stupid [__] that we that we exercise
this
way and we let them get away with it
without [__] saying something about
it just like Jenna Ellis you think I
feel you think I think she's some kind
of [__] hero [__] her she was
standing there in the [__] white
house and these son of a [__] are
telling her he ain't going nowhere and
she was telling him that ain't how it
works we don't give a [__] and she stood
by him up until two weeks
ago two weeks ago when her ass was in a
ringer [__] Jenna Ellis [__] that
traitor treasonous piece of [__]
[__] these people are not [__]
Patriots they don't love this [__]
country they don't they don't love this
rep public they don't give a [__] about
the people who are here either they
don't care about one goddamn thing and
that's the money in their [__]
pocket and if you can't sit there and
tell me that I'm oh Tony you're full of
[__] Jonathan Carl such a good
journalist blah blah blah blah and Jin
saki get the [__] out of here pluck your
head out of your ass stop being so
goddamn cult-like
you can look at Jonathan Carl and say
hey man that's a [__] scummy thing to
do you need to [__] you we we need to
get right in this [__] country it's
enough of this
[__] holding up Liz Cheney as some
kind of [__] hero because she did the
bare minimum at liberals acting like
they'd vote for that [__] [__] [__]
her She [__] hates women wants to
take Women's Health Care rights away
from them says the [__] lie about how
women want to kill their babies outside
the womb
you stupid [__] holding up Adam
keninger some kind of hero and and Jenna
Ellis and anyone else who [__] who
[__] tells the truth are you kidding
me that's the [__] bare minimum for
being a hero now in this country [__]
that [__] and Jonathan Carl can't even
[__] tell us can't even tell us who
the [__] it is live on air because he's
trying to sell him some
books son of a
[__] [__] I I've had a lot of people
tell me I've had a lot of people say
this to me in my comments one day Tony's
going to turn right
wing he'll sell out that's what they all
[__] say [__] I could have done sold
out already you dumb bastards I could
have sold out and sold out and sold out
again and you know
it [__] I could I could go right-wing
right now and sell out and I'd [__]
make I'd make all I'd make mountains of
money with what I do every day but I
[__] believe in
democracy I believe that there's there
is a [__] battle that is happening
right now and there is World War III of
misinformation [__] we see it with Hamas
and Israel right now it's playing out
time and time every [__] minute on
social
media every [__] minute this shit's
playing
out right Wingers all over the world it
doesn't matter matter if they're [__]
if they're white Christian nationalists
or they're goddamn they're fascist
Muslims it doesn't [__]
matter they're trying to sell you a bill
of goods and get deep inside your mind
and convince you of [__] that you don't
need to be convinced
of and for Jonathan Carl and Jin saki
now again I I'm roping them in because
they're in an interview together because
Jonathan Carl would not get away with
this [__] for me hell I interviewed
Anthony scaramucci and called him out on
it about his [__]
book they won't get they would wouldn't
get one [__] inch from me not
one for them for Jenna Ellis to hold
this information until her ass is in a
ringer in Georgia and she's going to go
to a Georgia State Penitentiary for her
to hold this
information from us cuz that's what she
did [__] she withheld it from
us
she knew she [__] knew and she had
the Patriotic duty to get out front of
the microphone to matter what the
[__] legal consequences and tell us
hey man they're talking about in the
White House how he's never going to
[__]
leave if all these [__] that are
[__] doing it now would have went
then in December of
2020 and did what they're doing
now that [__] there wouldn't
have been a January 6
and some righties think oh well [__]
that's why that's why the left wants
January 6 and so they could just pound
us on
it well I'm here to [__] tell you I'm
here to tell you I would rather not have
that in our [__] history
books where a [__] president is such
a [__] baby he's the little kid in
the grocery store then he get the
[__] cereal he
wanted that little [__] you know what
I'm talking about h might be your kid I
don't [__]
know but that little that little
[__] such a goddamn petulent
child drove his supporters to the
capital to hang his vice president to
overthrow the
government you think I want that in our
[__] history you think I want that to
damage our
democracy this decade next decade a 100
years from now folks that has long-term
effect
on the foundation of our [__]
freedoms I don't know if you know that
or not that's why I speak out I don't
give a [__] who it
is I don't care who it is and I don't
care what they're doing
now we need to get
right and the only way to get right is
to point our strategic outrage in a
direction that changes this [__]
where these fascists crawl back
underneath their
rocks they're trying to take your
[__] country away from you Inch by
Inch by Inch by Inch by Inch by Inch
whether it's Mike Johnson Donald Trump
[__] Republican Governors Republican
Representatives Republican [__] State
House Republican Senators United States
Republican Senators like Tu Branch Tommy
tuberville that [__]
prick little by little by little little
by little by little normalizing fascism
every single [__]
day so they easily manipulated easily
brainwashed people start to believe Li
little bitty lies that way when we get
to the big lies they'll do Despicable
[__] like clap and cheer When Donald
Trump quotes mellini and Hitler and New
Hampshire calling Americans
verman calling for 1930 style Solutions
on
Americans and people want to yell and
scream about genocide you better [__]
watch out you better [__] watch out
and you better watch this show every
single [__] weekday Monday through
Friday new Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Facebook and twitch I it's
Tuesday we got Texas Paul here but I've
got a great guest before Texas Paul Jess
Piper is joining us I discovered
something about my state of Missouri and
then I started to look at a map and I
was like holy [__] there's a lot of
Republican
states that are making sure it seems
like a coincidence but it's not a
coincidence it seems planned there's a
lot of Republican states that are
keeping Wick participation to a minimum
and I want to talk to Jess Piper but of
course I know that this is all tied in
to Childhood hunger and education it is
Republicans trying to make sure that
people in rural areas think that the big
bad Democrats are coming after them I
almost guarantee that's what she's going
to tell me and I want to thank you I
want to thank you so much so that I want
to give you another chance here we got
coffee mugs even my cat hates Ted Cruz
and even my dog hates Ted Cruz coffee
month so go to the Tony michaels.com
catch those and don't go anywhere we'll
be right back as they see on the radio
right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you numb and alone after
storming the capital have you been left
out in the cold after stealing Nancy P's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that does doesn't share your patriotic
values if any of these describe you then
you're in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and
thanks to my new product paron blanket
I've got you covered paron blanket
specifically Works to make you feel safe
and cozy after your involvement on
January 6th and if you're one of the
other members of Congress who also
helped with the attempted coup part and
blanket will protect you too paron
blanket is made of a sort of soft fleece
and a layer of sheep's wool and there
are 100% made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
$99.99 actual pardon is not
guaranteed jumping back into it this is
the Tony Michaels
podcast welcome back to the
show it's Tuesday November 14th have a
great guest for you a return to the show
finally I'm so excited to have her I'm
glad we could fit her in this schedule I
know she's going to be very busy out
speaking in all those R areas to tell
them why they actually are blue this is
important stuff this is important work
that she does her name is Jess Piper and
you we've had her on the show she's one
of your favorite the audience favorite
guest and this morning I was reading a
story about Wick and Wick payments and
it seemed to be that there's a new study
that showed that Missouri and Arkansas
um and other states but Missouri and
Arkansas have a low participation lead
I'm talking below 40% which was kind of
weird to me I was like this is federal
funding this isn't State funding and I
text my friend Jess Piper and I said
this does not seem like a coincidence
and she said it is not it is planned so
I said come on the show and let's let's
talk about this [__] we got to talk
about this and you know smoke this out
give this awareness so welcome back Jess
Piper I'm so glad to have you my friend
here on the Tony Michaels podcast it's
Tony it's good to see you again so tell
us you're traveling around the state
doing these speeches and I know you're
we we kind of fit in the schedule for
today so tell us about these speeches
and then we'll get to the wick stuff um
and I'm sure we'll talk about education
too because it's Jess Viper so yeah I'm
gonna be in St Louis tomorrow I'm
speaking to a group of people who are
trying to get uh Empower other women to
run and then really fun on col um on
Thursday Friday I'm in Columbia on
Thursday Springfield on Friday and it's
a Clean Water conference so I'm speaking
with um experts on a panel about what's
happening with Missouri's water we have
a scientist coming down from Iowa
because I know people think about the
water in Iowa probably that it's
pristine or something but it's actually
full of hog [__] and um and so those
people have now ruined Iowa and now
they're looking South to Missouri and um
so I'm hitting the road with these
people to talk about how we can save our
water in Missouri
you know it's kind of funny that we sit
here and have to um beat back these
fascists with Pro Federal programs where
our state isn't participating like Wick
um where it's it's helped it's it's it
is designed to help fight childhood
hunger and child hunger um where
Missouri is doing so much thing so many
things in education and um school
lunches and it's insane that we have to
sit here and and talk about these
subjects that should be pretty easy
feeding kids should not be that
controversial that way we we could pay
attention to things like hog [__] in the
water um you know because Farmers rely
on those waterways I don't know if
people know that and your food on your
table relies on those waterways being
clean so it it's all you know a big loop
and we're all in this together um but
why why is this Wick thing because I I
read the story this morning I'm like and
I sent it to you and I thought um she's
got to know about this I know she's got
her thumb on this one so tell me why if
I was to say that this is oh it's
totally a Co incidence that Missouri and
Arkansas are below 40% participa tell me
why I'm wrong I know I'm not I know I'm
not but tell me why I'm wrong you're not
wrong and this is how I know I am
originally from Arkansas so I made the
lateral move uh to Missouri and um it's
because that we live under super
majorities who often send back federal
funds for absolutely no reason I don't
know if you remember but during coid um
the federal government sent us millions
of dollars to give to Hungry kids who
weren't in school it took Missouri an
entire year to disperse those funds um
the kids were already back in school by
the time they got those funds and then
Tony last year or last session Mike
Parson returned $47 million of federal
money uh for Hungry kids uh for their
lunches because we couldn't figure out
how to disperse the fund so we just sent
it back well again Wick and you can
describe Wick probably better than I can
uh I I I know that you probably are very
familiar with the program and the ins
and outs of it and why it is important
to to not just Missouri families but
American families it's the reason why
it's a ferally funded program um but I
get so frustrated because we we want
States um cheer and and they do such a
great job of doing school lunch for
everyone um which should be part of
Education I've always felt like you know
our communities have infrastructure for
hunger and the the main infrastructure
for Hunger is the school cafeteria like
that's like that's the we didn't really
realize it when we DEC decided to embark
on public education so many so many you
know over hundred years ago but we we
didn't understand that we were going to
build an infrastructure that could feed
communities but that's literally what
that building does is it not only
educates students but it feeds those
children as well and I can't even
believe that we can't wrap our minds
around that idea that we have the
infrastructure we have the ability to
make sure that kids kids we're talking
about and they saved the children people
you know of all people are like no no
thank you we don't want the wick we
don't cuz tell me what what Wick is and
tell me why it's intentional that
Missouri it feels like to me in this in
this article that I had from the
Missouri independent that I sent you it
feels like to me that the Republicans of
Missouri aren't doing their due
diligence to let citizens know that hey
These funds are available for you not to
have to spend so much on groceries
because if you don't spend as much on
groceries maybe you won't blame your
plight on who I want you to blame it on
right because it feels like that's what
Republicans are truly doing yeah wh uh
Wick is women infant and children and so
it's a program for pregnant women and
women who have children I believe up to
um age five I actually participated in
the program um I had my first son at 20
years old I was married um and my
husband worked full-time and I worked
full-time at Walmart but we still
couldn't make ends meat and so it gave
me eggs and peanut butter and cereal and
milk things that I needed to to fill up
my son and things that were and beans
too things that were nutritionally good
for him what's happening in Missouri is
that uh most people who and this is
confusing to people most people who
participate in Wick also work we aren't
talking about people who aren't working
these are working folks um just like I
was and the problem with Missouri is you
have to go to your local um you know
Health Department to get your card
updated well you have to go during work
hours and so that makes it almost
impossible for working folks to fill
their card um at the same time every
other state nearly has figured this out
you do it online and it comes
automatically it's automatically filled
but in Missouri we make working moms
take off and how are they going to take
off because they've lost some money and
then drive to their local you know um
DHS to fill that card up so we've made
it difficult for working folks to get
things that that they need and that the
federal government is providing so what
you're saying is because I read that in
the article that really there was a big
push during a pandemic because there
extra money given to Wick because during
the pandemic they were trying to
overload uh families to make sure that
they had enough to eat I I I mean it's
crazy to think that you know we were
trying to make sure people weren't
hungry in this country uh as rich as we
are and as rich as we claim to be um but
the thing was is that Missouri was very
reluctant and by Missouri I mean
Republicans because that's who controls
the state they were very reluctant into
bringing that program on online and the
reason why is just what you're saying
now
I I want to I want to give you an idea
because the new speaker of the house um
he loves online accountability Partners
so much so that he's willing to to
download an app to look at his son's
born and to have his son look at his
born it's kind of weird stuff I'm not
sounds like grooming it's really weird
stuff it's weird really weird stuff it
doesn't sound educational it doesn't
sound like accountability it just sounds
like sounds creepy you want to know the
honest truth but Mike Johnson's for that
kind of electronic online accountability
but he definitely in Republicans in
general and I I would say it's probably
the white Christian nationalists that
are really uh in this Camp they don't
want women to to have access online to
receive food for their children I mean I
thought they were to save the children
people no they Tony they don't want
women to work oh oh oh I I see I see I
see so they don't want women to work
right they can get the money as long as
they stay home I don't know how they
have a car when they stay home but you
know these are things they they actually
don't care about
well let's talk about that because
that's the other thing uh my wife read
the other day she was like oh my gosh
because we know it's been almost a year
since Missouri's had recreational
marijuana yeahum and they've had a huge
boom as every state does because you
take a a an industry that's in the dark
and you bring it out in the light and
bingo bango bongo you tax a little bit
you got a lot of Revenue and my wife
said oh my gosh this is great Missouri
and I said no don't don't get too much
in a hurry I said the first thing
they're going to do is give that money
to the rich people and start cutting
education um because they can't stop
talking about vouchers and they can't
stop talking uh about school vouchers
and I know it's something that you are
continually in the battle for so tell me
what your thoughts are am I crazy out of
my mind when when I tell when I tell my
wife oh don't get excited about that
money yet because I don't think it's
gonna come down to schools well let me
tell you this they when we passed the
lottery that money was supposed to go to
fund education and it did Tony but this
is what they did whatever the lottery
brings in they take it from what they
were going to send to schools anyway so
it was a net gain of zero to Public
Schools it was shady as hell it was
smoking mirrors and people all the time
were like what about the lottery money
well here you go friends so the weed
money is supposed to go to Veterans and
I guarantee you I guarantee you the same
thing is going to happen with that
they'll say yeah it's going to Veterans
and then take out whatever in the budget
they were going to send anyway and this
voucher scheme is absolutely Ely
pummeling the entire country and the
reason I talk about it so much is
because they are going to push it
through no matter what voters want they
do it behind closed doors because they
know it's unpopular school choice has
been on the voucher in several States it
has never one because people don't want
to defund their local school to send it
to private and religious schools even
private people who send their kids to
private schools don't believe it even
religious people don't believe it right
this is I always call it welfare for for
the welltoo because what happens is and
I'll just give you an example in
Missouri they did a study they just
passed a learns bill which is a voucher
Bill and they did the first study on it
and guess what 95% of the kids there
were 4,800 95% of them were already in a
private school so their parents were
given a coupon from the taxpayers of
Arkansas to take care of part of their
tuition it wasn't for poor people it
wasn't for black or brown people it
wasn't for dis disabled people it was
for people who were already in private
schools it's a scam and you know that's
a good um point and you said because
they call it school choice you know
that's that's their kind of like right
to work sounds great right it sounds
great but it's the school they want to
choose for you right it's their choice
of the school that they want you to have
it's not school choice it's hey we're
we're the fascist Republicans and we not
the community not you electing a school
I think people they they they don't
understand even though they've been
through this process and they've had
kids to go to school they don't fully
understand that the commun local
communities controled their school
districts um and and they do that by not
not only making sure that the federal
funds get to the state level and the
state funds get to the state level and
then get to the local level but then you
elect school boards to that school
district it's an election folks it's
called democracy and you actually elect
the people who run your school like if
if the principal's a [__] which
there are some that are the school board
can say hey you're a [__] you're
fired you're fired oh we're not going to
do this thing anymore because this is
sucking for our community so I I think
people have gotten out of this and
they've been diluted into thinking that
the the teachers bad the school board
bad democracy bad right this is all bad
it democracy bad because you shouldn't
want to elect your school board members
what you should want is you should want
the church to tell you what to do with
education and it's it's more of this
white Christian fascism is what I think
it is and and that's that's the
right-wing Cooks but when you knock on
doors and you talk to people they know
their kids teacher they know she doesn't
have a litter box in her room they know
she doesn't have porn on her bookshelf
they know Mrs Smith is doing whatever
she came for their kids and they don't
want their schools defunded and so that
is where the Republicans are falling
apart and that's why they have to pass
school choice behind closed doors with
um bills that their their donors wrote
because it is not popular and that's why
if you follow me on any social media you
see I am bombarded by the biggest Folks
by Corey d'angelus who is the right hand
of Betsy DeVos he is at me every day I
am a rule woman in the middle of nowhere
in the sticks in Arkansas I mean in
Missouri now but he spends so much time
on me me and you're like dude you are
bolstering my point you're proving the
point and they can't attack me and they
can't come after me because this is this
is why I am who I say I am my kid goes
to a public school all five of my kids
went to a public school three of my
grandkids are in a public school I'm
standing for what my community needs
what my kid needs and they know there is
no choice in rule parts of America and I
just wrote I just did a Tik Tok on it
today but I want to tell your listeners
this you will hear the say all the time
Market Solutions everyone deserves a
choice competition makes schools better
all right I live in a town of 480 people
I don't have a coffee shop a Walmart a
grocery store a Target there is no
competition out here so you tell me who
is going to come and bring a school to
my area no one absolutely no one so what
are these kids left with defunded
schools you pulled the money away from
the schools and you sent it to your
private you know Pals wherever who were
lying in their pockets and you left our
kids without a school and you know
they've been doing it for years because
30% of the schools in Missouri are
running a 4-day school week and none of
them are private none of them they're
all public well and I'll I'll tell you
that the if those are your enemies
you're doing something right I mean
you're really you're doing it right if
those are the people that are coming
after you every day and I watch them
because there's Missouri reps that tweet
about school choice just because they're
terrified of you yeah like like they're
like well we got to write three tweets
today because Jess Piper's going to be
out there doing Tik toks getting
hundreds of millions of views so we
better we better write a few tweets
today and act like we still believe in
the stuff that we're saying we believe
in and it and it just it I I want to go
back to the wick thing because I know it
feels like maybe the wick U because it's
federally funded but schools are
federally funded too um and it feels
like that these things are
interconnected um the the the family
part of this because these are kitchen
table things for most people and I want
to put people in a sense that if if you
didn't have this plight where you were a
young mother or young family um maybe in
your late teens early 20s you didn't
really have a career yet maybe you
didn't make it to College yet maybe
you're working at the grocery store or
the Walmart like you said in town barely
making ends meat and you all of a sudden
have a baby right now you got this now
you got this extra mouth to feed and you
go down to the Health and Human Service
office and they tell you look we know
you can't afford food but these little
coupons because that's kind of what they
are now it needs to be online but in
Missouri it's not or it's a card but
they give you a little card or coupons
and they say look you can go get you
some milk you can get you some eggs you
can get some beans you can get some rice
that way you can eat you can feed you
and your family you would think you
would would think that the people who
are like oh we want to make sure people
have choices and people have options you
think those people would be for I don't
know making sure that the people in
there in rural communities know about
this Wick program because I think it was
39 and a half percent is the actual
participation rate uh in Missouri now I
I looked at Arkansas it was a little
lower it's like 37 some percent and I'm
not really much on data and facts and
stuff but it it's clear
that there is a this this through line
between Republicans controlling a state
and trying to convince people that hey
it's not your fault it's someone else's
fault while it's the Republican's fault
that isn't showing these people hey
there are these programs you are the
government you are electing people at a
federal level to make sure that you have
food on your table yes are groceries
high is inflation going back is is
groceries getting better yeah but
they're not better yet so here here's
Wick you have little kids you're a
single mom or you're or you're a small
family you're a new family here here's
some food here's some food for you these
things are available and it feels like
Republicans are like we can't tell them
we can't tell them this stuff's a
because maybe just maybe they'll be like
you know maybe I should stop voting for
the people who are taking [__] away from
me huh what do you think do you think
the wick and the education and taking
away your school and all the stuff is
interconnected it's got to be right it's
all connected and I would say because
you know how I feel about Republicans
but in the case of Wick and in the case
of sending uh back the school uh lunch
money that we sent the 47 million the
problem is not necessarily that they're
evil in this instance it's that they're
incompetent they can't they have not
created the infrastructure in Missouri
government to allow them to distribute
funds and Tony like people should know
that is a major thing
that makes companies who may think of
relocating to Missouri think twice well
they'll think twice one because our
schools are 49th and Educational Funding
and the fact that we have child care
deserts everywhere and the fact that you
know rural hospitals are closing
everywhere um and also that we don't
have bodily autonomy but the fact that
our government can't even get rid of
money that it took in from the feds is a
big issue it's definitely connected but
it goes this part is just being stupid
and incompetent well you know the other
thing too is Republicans maybe we could
frame it up a little better cuz I got
I've got trolls and maanga trolls that
watch me you know I'm not scared of
manga or are the trolls I actually W and
I know you do too you're like come on in
come on in let's have fun let's have fun
I'll show you a thing or two um but I I
have to to give them a sense of maybe
I'll change your direction and
perspective think about the grocery
stores all those groceries those big
corporations that own them groceries
think about how much more money them
grocery stores in Missouri could could
make if you could just convince
Republicans to tell people that this
Wick program exists and they would get
the federal dollars the grocery stores
the the employees that work there the
people who they maybe they'd have to
hire more people and Jess Jess Piper
maybe they would I you know maybe that's
the angle that you have to take with
these people sometimes because they
don't fully understand because they just
don't have uh seems to have empathy um
in the in their hearts so I W to I want
to talk about one other thing here real
quick um then I have I've been thinking
a lot about and I always I always seem
to come back to this the schools and the
education um because it's so important
to a lot of communities like you said
you you may not have a coffee shop you
may not have a Walmart or uh you know
you may not have a handmaid's tail
costume shop in your town um they want
one but you may not have one um but you
normally got a school yeah and in that
school there's a lot of different things
for the community um there's a library
that that's vitally important to those
children in their learning um their
structure which structure is is really
important there's physical education to
teach people exercise there's all kinds
of things in that school uh there's
Sports there's activities there's art I
don't know if you know this holy moly
most schools have art they sing they
dance they draw they paint they do all
kinds of thing that's good for Humanity
but the one thing that a school has
every public school has that I go into
that I've been in they have a
cafeteria and it's it feels like to me
in this country we are not having the
conversation with the save the children
crowd that hey you know what you're
right let's save the children there is a
huge infrastructure that we have in this
country that can feed families not just
the children but we can feed families
what if we kept those cafeterias open
for dinner for those families of those
kids that go to school what if we I mean
we have the infrastructure we could do
that couldn't we I mean is this am I out
of my mind to think that there should be
some sort of national push to to to use
the infrastructure that we have in
public schools and to value that
infrastructure um to feed children and
to feed families I don't think that any
kid who goes to school should have a
lunch debt I I don't believe in you know
charging kids for food I've worked in
places where if kids didn't have money
on their balance they were given a
cheese sandwich rather than what the
rest of the kids were having which is
shame ful um for us as a society but
also create shame in a child um I
definitely believe in you know nutrition
and what Public Schools um have to offer
every community and just like you said
public schools are the epicenter of
places like mine I we don't have a lot
but we are all in the same place on
Friday night we're all watching football
or basketball we all vote in the same
place we all go to watch the School
Musical we all go to the Christmas plays
we all go to the school to eat at the
cafeteria for the Thanksgiving dinner
that you know with our kids that we've
always done and that's the that's the
thing that uh Republicans are trying to
destroy in Missouri and if I can for
just one second I have had a lot of
interactions today with a state
representative named Josh Hurlbert who
was from Smithville Missouri and he is a
state representative but he also works
for the Herzog foundation and the Herzog
Foundation is a Foundation that wants to
accelerate Christian um education in
Missouri they are one of the
institutions that is in charge of
handling our ESA voucher scheme so Josh
is a State Rep and he also works for a
corporation that is you know using State
funds to fund private schools Josh has
written almost half a dozen bills to
expand school choice and to me that is a
glaring you know um he shouldn't be able
to to benefit to write bills that
benefit his Corporation but here's the
thing every day every day on Twitter he
talks about our great private schools in
my area he knows where I live he's
basically doxing me and my daughter and
he says this school costs $113,000 but
you can take her to St Greg's and it's
only $44,000 well listen here Josh St
Gregs is a 20 minute drive for me St
Greg's cost $4,000 that I don't have and
St Greg's does not have a free lunch
program right so you got to have gas you
got to have time you got to have lunch
you got to have money to get your kid 20
minutes away or I could send them to the
free school but all Josh is concerned
about is devastating our schools in
Northwest Missouri to send that money to
private and religious schools to take
away the only infrastructure we have
left and this is what everyone should
know Tony our towns are dying rule decay
is massive in Missouri we don't build
things in my town we knock down the
buildings that are falling down and when
he takes our school away when he if they
are able to finally take our school away
there's nothing left our children will
not come home our children will our
grandchildren will never live here our
little Farms will go away and we will
move to the towns and cities like they
want us to do and that's what they want
clear out rule America bring in the Kos
bring in you know huge a and just take
over and folks need to to wake up and
realize what's going on you don't need a
tinfoil hat you need to look around and
see what these representatives are doing
and know that they mean business well
the Republicans Hogs are [__] in the
Stream and it's running Downstream you
see that there that's how fast we get
images here at the Tony Michaels podcast
we show all the Republicans polluting
the the stream with their hog [__] um
and then they triy to sell it to you as
as clean pristine water is what these
what these Republicans trying to sell it
to is and also I want to show you
another image here this is um apparently
there's a protest going on it says Tony
they don't want women to work don't want
women to work Jess Piper I'm so glad to
have you on and I know uh that you're
doing the hard work out there to try to
bring awareness to these issues it's why
I like having you on the show because um
I think the issues that you're talking
about with rule Americans if rule
Americans really did the math and and
did some thinking they would go oh okay
well I probably shouldn't vote
Republican then um I probably shouldn't
because all they want to do is destroy
my community enjoy it blame it on Hunter
Biden's laptop that's what they want to
do they want to blame my community on
Hunter Biden's laptop so tell the
audience where they can find you because
this is so vitally important folks if
you want to know about education if you
want to know about these Republicans
plan for school choice the school that
they want you to go to uh tell us where
to find all that cont content yes if
they I work for uh blue Missouri if they
could go to Blu missouri. org my entire
my entire purpose in life right now is
raising money for down ballot candidates
in Missouri who normally don't get a
dime from the party so I'm sending them
as much as they can you guys can join me
be a member we meet once a month and we
talk about these things so Blu missouri.
org and also you can find me on Twitter
and Tik Tok and Facebook at um at Piper
for Missouri or you can follow her
trolls and you'll find her
if you follow the trolls you'll find
Jess or you just follow Jess either way
because they're talking about her every
day I'm serious these these fragile
white men in this state they are
terrified of you that that that's one
reason why to be your friend is just
that one and you're nice and you are
have so knowledgeable about these things
that's another reason too but um when
the right people hate you you know
you're you're on track to do good things
so ex Jess get out there and do good
things I know you got some meetings and
some stuff
so thank you for joining me thanks for
having the conversation today about Wick
and education we'll see you yes thank
you and audience stick around we'll be
right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast trying to remember all the
things you boycotted can really get you
stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having having a
cluttered mess call now and get the
boycott binder for just
$29.99 plus you'll also receive our next
rep as a bonus just Loop it around your
neck to travel with ease but call right
now and we'll double the offer that's
two boycott binders and two neck straps
for just
$29.99 boycott binders brought to you by
the same makers of binders full of
women jumping back into it this is the
Tony Michaels
podcast
welcome back to the show Jess
Piper always a
great she knows so much she's so [__]
smart holy
moly you're never going to catch her off
guard
either doesn't
matter they never catch her off guard
either like I said when you have the typ
of trolls that she has you know she's
doing some good work oh trust me these
are these are the scummiest of the
scummiest of the
scumbags the scummiest of the
scummy it really
is I mean you think you think you think
you got some scummy trolls oh my God
just go look at Jess Piper's comments
and you'll see it everyone says she's
fantastic she is fantastic she is
fantastic and I'm I'm happy to have her
here and I'm I'm happy to that that
democracy has someone out there fighting
for uh not just rule Missouri but rule
America um and and trying to really do
the hard long game work that it takes
because it is going to take a long hard
game you know real people aren't just
going to change their affiliation uh
with these with these fascists overnight
it's going to take a long time for them
to realize that hey I've been voting
against my self-interest in my
communities for interest for so long
because these Republicans don't give a
[__] about me they don't give a [__]
about my community they only care about
their own
power they only care about their own
power and boy am I going to show you
some clips of that today holy [__] but
it's Tuesday and you know what Tuesday
is a taco Tuesday but it's also Texas
Paul Tuesday Texas Paul welcome back to
the show did you catch most of that with
Jess Piper oh yeah man I I that's why I
have to apologize for bouncing right in
the middle of the transition
I Jess Piper is such a great guest I
just I lost track of time and I was like
oh man I better go pee quick you know I
ran out there to go hit the bathroom and
sorry about that man no she's she's a
great guest and she's so smart and and
um she has her she had because not only
did she run in rule Missouri but she
lives in rule Missouri and she's from
rule Arkansas so she you know she knows
R areas she knows real people she knows
that most R people aren't you know just
all in fascist I mean this this idea
it's more affiliation than anything uh
that happens in these rural areas than
it is you know people being being true
fascist but but we got um we've got a
couple things to talk about today Texas
Paul I got several Clips I want to show
you I want to get to this Jenna Ellis
clip oh my God but first off I want to
show you um that the the wiener the
wiener of the house micro Johnson let's
see if I we haven't played that song Oh
Hell let's let's let's see if we can
find that song people like that song
wiener of the house I maybe we a't got
it I don't know oh here election tonight
that'll work
here the of the house
[Music]
Johnson wienner of the house micro
Johnson here he is on the screen micro
Johnson let's listen to what he has to
say about Trump and his head up Trump's
ask this morning um on the Squawk Box or
whatever the hell it is you been to a
country bar
expect he'll be our nominee yeah and I'm
I'm he's all up Trump's ass Texas Paul
he's all in for president Trump this
morning the Speaker of the House said
that what what what was your question
I'm sorry I I terribly rooted me I
didn't mean to interrupt your video I
didn't see it coming up why you pulling
up I was just going to ask you ever been
to a country bar yeah of course I have
have I I go to a country bar every
week I love as you know down here in
Texas we all wear these I mean you don't
have to be a cowboy to wear these you
don't it's just the culture you know
what it is um but you go to a country
bar down here in Texas man they start
playing a song like that and they start
dancing it is freaking hilarious to look
at the dance floor because it looks like
like Mario Brothers mushrooms all got
together you mean you mean mushroom
mushrooms like this who are simping for
Donald Trump now let's talk about this
for a second um because um Mike Row
Johnson the speaker of the house uh is
doing what I said the speaker whoever
the speaker was going to be was going to
do was going to punt the government
shutdown to January past the holidays
because the last thing that the
Republicans want is for families to get
together and blame Republicans for a
government shutdown because that's what
would happen if they shut down the
government um in the next few days now I
believe they're supposed to vote on this
thing at uh 4:30 I believe so it'll
probably the vote they'll probably pass
the CR about 5 5:30 Eastern which is
about 4:30 our time
um that seems like what's going to
happen because Democrats are not going
to let they should I think they should
but Democrats are not going to let the
government um close uh they're just
they're too serious about not what we
vote for man it's not what we do right I
mean we responsible human beings that
believe on keeping believe in keeping
the lights on my brother I mean Jesus
well I mean you know I'm I'm all for the
responsibility and the seriousness but
at some point you have to let the child
touch the stove because they won't
[__] learn that it's hot um I mean
you you got to do that I mean here's
another scumbag speaking of [__]
scumbags in Washington here's Tommy two
branches here talking about the uh
listen this is crazy [__] this is on
Greg Kelly's news Mac Show Greg Kelly
reports it should be called Greg Kelly
pukes up [__] um but it's not called
that here on Newsmax listen to what
Tommy tuberville says listen to how he
describes military personnel getting
promotions that they have been given
listen Greg but tomorrow I think in the
rules committee Schumer sending over a
resolution to bypass what I'm doing
through the rules committee it have to
be voted on in the Senate and have to
get 60 votes uh but U I'm here and we've
got some Republicans that might vote for
it and put it 60 plus and it would pass
and and these promotions would uh would
go through hopefully that doesn't happen
we're going to continue to fight um we
should not give them a win on this we
should not give them a win on this Texas
Paul he does not want people promoted in
the military now a lot of people a lot
of people have been saying why and what
what for why this guy's doing this um
this morning on MSNBC I heard that oh
it's just it's just Tommy Tu branch is
really trying to say the word abortion
as many times as he can what I really
want to know about the issue because I
actually think that there's something
more Sinister going on here but what I
want to know is who the [__] is paying
him to say that military personnel
getting their promotions that they've
been given by do these aren't like these
aren't like newbies that are being being
deemed generals these are people who've
been in the military for their entire
career they've earned these promotions
they've been given these promotions but
they have to be voted on and confirmed
by the Senate normally it's done with
one blanket vote they approve all these
promotions but Tommy tuberville is
making him do it one by one he's
objecting each one so that they can't
even do it one by one and he's
complaining that Chuck Schumer is going
to change the rules and Republicans are
going to vote for these rules because
they're [__] tired of his [__] but
these [__] scumbags listen if you
want to know what the hell project 2025
and you want to know what these
Republicans plan are with with Donald
Trump being the next term this is only
this Tommy tuberville [__] is only a
preview of it yeah absolutely absolutely
and I'm loving what you know military
personel can't get in there are
limitations to how they can get involved
in politics so you have former military
personnel have you have you seen what
these families are doing these people
are doing you've got former officers
that are coalescing together into a
group I don't have a name for them yet
but they're forming into a group and
they are going to Lobby Republicans and
threaten them they're basically going to
say look we have been a reliable
Republican vote forever that is over if
you don't get this Tommy T tuberville
[__] under control they I'm I am
absolutely loving it this guy first of
all it didn't start about abortion you
know that you saw when it happened it
started because the military engaged in
a program to root out white supremacist
because white supremacist terrorism is
the number one threat we Face Lord knows
we shouldn't have it in our own
military tuberville went nuts that's
when he started putting the holds on the
Republican uh
in came to him said you can't do that
you can't be on the record for that you
have to say it's about abortion you have
to say it about then we can make money
on it and then you know you don't get
hurt for saying that you're protecting
white supremacist this is not did not
originate about abortion it didn't it
was about rooting white supremacy out of
the military then they morphed it into
their catchall project that gets
right-wingers to vote no matter what
because they're idiots about abortion
they started saying oh it's all about
abortion it's not it's just not this is
about keeping their freaking radical
base in the military it is man and I I I
well how having said that if that's the
full truth there what my suspicion is is
that there's a guy in Texas who owns a
signed copy of mine cop behind this I'm
just going to put that out there I would
say that what it is uh uh the shart Army
is speaking here on Facebook and we
can't offend them Texas Paul because
they're
snowflakes we can't we can't offend them
The Shard Army um but shans says our
military has become politicized it is
not part of our core Mission listen you
[__] buffoon Tommy tuberville is
politicizing the military you dumb son
of a [__] what what don't you
understand about politicization you
[__] [__] what don't you understand
about it this is politicizing the
military it is Tommy tuberville that is
politicizing these ranks within the
within the internal workings of the
military this isn't Joe Biden picked
these [__] promotions the military
the military the same military that
Trump had the same military that you
want Dan santis to have if he were to
win which is laughable um he can't even
walk in a pair of high heel sh how the
hell is he gonna be president but the
point is is that watch's true he can't
walk in a pair high heels the dude needs
to take some [__] lessons really
honestly Texas ball I think should stop
Banning drag uh drag queens in Florida
and he should go learn how to walk in
high heels with for them with from them
like he really he really could appear um
to be much taller and he would do much
better walking in high heels if he would
just go seek out the counsil of you know
a professional a drag queen I mean he
wants to walk around and drag but you
know I'm just saying you can't hide what
he's doing you know Robert Downey Jr
does that exact same if you look at the
shoes Robert Downey Jr wears they're
always very long across the bridge of
his foot because he inserts lifts inside
when he does like red carpets and what
cuz Robert Dan Jr is very short he just
is any date he gets I mean he dates you
know he has hot escorts on the red
carpet uh but they tend to be taller
than him so he puts these lifts inside
his shoes and you could tell it's
happening because it backs your shoes up
it backs your foot up out of the shoes
and the shoe breaks at the wrong spot
right you know normally breaks over your
toes you know what I mean boots do that
every picture you see of Rona santis his
boot is breaking dead in the middle of
the damn boot I mean it's like squished
completely flat because that's where
it's breaking and there's nothing there
there's no foot under it to support it
he's literally walking on arches that
are shoved inside his boots he's walking
on his tiptoes you ever you ever walked
in a pair of flip fers you walked in a
pair of flippers that's what it's like
yes it's like he's wearing were G to ask
me about walking in high heels I'm like
what stays in Vegas what
happened hey man I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna hate on someone who
who's walking in high heels and I you
know I don't want to make fun of
mushrooms are a hell of a drug my man
they are a hell of a drug do they make
you want to wear high heels I don't know
I don't know but shad's here Shad here
doesn't shad's in The Shard doesn't
don't understand the word politicized
number one because uh Tommy tuberville
is the one who's politicizing this issue
and he's not they're not the only
Republicans politicizing uh issues uh
actually we got a hang on I got an image
here you asked me if I've been to a
country bar and this is the country bar
that I attend um every single week
here's the here's the here's the um
here's what it looks
like this is a picture this is a live a
live picture this is a picture of when I
go to the bar um what it looks like here
the Texas tell I'm rur as hell but that
is some funny [__] right there I'm
telling you nothing like I it has always
cracked me up my entire life man it's
one thing when you got a good country
song On and you're just gliding around
the floor and this that and the other
but it's another thing when you got it
you know like a hipop song comes on and
it's
like and you should just see the
mushroom yeah well here I want to show
you another scumbag here
Representative Bob good I don't know if
you know who this guy is you probably
heard of Bob he's not good by the way
he's he's an [__] I mean he's a good
[__] if you you know if you're
counting that but here's Bob good he's
gonna talk about I I find this funny and
the reason why is because Shaz is in the
comments he's like Democrats are
politicizing the military but it's Tommy
tuberville politicizing the the [__]
promotions that the military wants with
something like a abortion but here's
another stupid [__] trying to politicize
an issue in the wrong direction and I I
actually I hope Bob good keeps this up
listen to this narrative here um where
he's talking about the election in
Virginia listen this we just came off of
an election in Virginia and the
narrative now is oh abortions a loser we
got to surrender on abortion we got to
give in on abortion we got to be like
the Democrats on abortion then maybe we
can win elections I would argue what's
the point of winning elections if you're
not going to fight for life but but
beyond that what was Virginia's position
what was the state of Virginia political
leaders position on abortion we're okay
with 94% of abortions because we want a
15we ban and the Democrats the other
side wants 100% of abortion so we're GNA
rally in the red areas and the the the
conservatives and the red base uh to
fight for six% of abortions and I submit
that's the reason why we had low red
turnout in Virginia for those who are
reading into that this was all about one
particular issue that people didn't vote
on inflation and grocery prices and gas
prices and crime and the border and
education everything else that we're
winning on we lost only because
everybody who voted in Virginia was
voting on whether not they could have
abortions up to the moment ab and have
you have to pay for with your tax
dollars so what he's saying here in
Texas Paul here's what Bob good is
saying he's [__] delusional this is
wild stuff that he has even postulating
this he is saying that people who are
who are prli stayed home on this
election because because that that they
weren't being pro-life enough that that
Glenn yunan wasn't being pro life up
that Glenn yunan didn't sell
abortion enough Glenn yunan went around
the state and said hey just give me a
bunch of [__] crazies and I'll pass
the abortion bill you want and people
like [__] you like I'm more clear can
Bob good get the signal here but this is
this is the problem that you have with
fascism this is the problem you have
with fascist y can I be brutal for a
second I mean just brutal absolutely
yeah okay you are pregnant do you you
your Tony your wife is pregnant mhm I
want you to just imagine this for a
second you're driving down the street
you get broadsided by a drunk
driver your wife is set to give birth in
two weeks two weeks
man and your child is now dead and your
wife is severely
injured that whole they want abortion up
to the point of
birthing is for that situation it is for
that situation it is so that your wife
can go in and get a
DNC if she's got a non-viable fetus
inside
her it's not anything to there are no
[__] doctors that are doing abortions
on viable fetuses past 28 weeks Tony you
know why they're not happening you know
you know why they're not because it's
because they're children at that point
illegal it's illegal yeah it's [__]
illegal and and and people like Bob good
are not only lying to their constituents
but they're lying to themselves because
Bob good here and I hope he keeps going
I honestly do not want Republicans to
change course on this um and the reason
why is because they're showing their
True Values here because Shaz says this
The Shard Army's upset that we're
talking about we're talking about Bob
good what he doesn't know about abortion
people don't even vote for things that
matter the whole abortion thing is
frankly disrespectful to our core
American values dude you obvious ly
don't know what abortion is this is the
point Bob good doesn't know what
abortion is and that's the point that
you were trying to make Texas Paul is
these [__] men these men don't
understand that this is Women's
Healthcare this has to do with their
Reproductive Rights sh Shaz doesn't get
that when a woman is pregnant she has
another individual that is utilizing her
body her organs everything from her and
she does not give up those rights to her
own bodily at autonomy because she is
pregnant because there's another being
inside her you know Shaz I know a guy
that had testic cancer and they had to
cut his nuts off you've got two we're
gonna take one buddy he needs one he
needs one to make babies you don't have
a choice that's the same damn thing Tony
it's the same damn thing a woman's body
is her body it is not her children's
body it is not an a fetus's body it is
her body period and in this country our
American values are that you cannot
force someone to have their nut cut off
just because I feel like it you know
it's the exact same damn thing stop
treating women like they don't have
rights over their own damn bodies that's
why these sons of [__] are rapists
because they cannot in their freaking
Minds understand that women are not here
for their
Services that's not why they're here
they are not cattle they are not your
birth vessel they're not your
entertainment and they're not your damn
sperm catcher that's not what they're
here for they're here to live their
lives uh Kimberly on Facebook makes a
really good point you're assuming Shez
has nuts I mean this is uh you're making
a really wild assumption there in Texas
Paul I mean you know I'm just saying got
ahead man I know I know I just I just
want the truth on this you know what I
mean and I don't I don't want to I don't
I don't want sh has testicles this right
this is this is not something we just
should assume we should we should have
some good evidence of it before we uh
cast disparagement and speaking of that
I want to show you um a tweet here from
SPO Agnus ghost um it's about your your
favorite cheeseburger it's about not not
McDonald's okay not McDonald's it's it's
your about your favorite cheeseburger
here is here's uh Kenneth
cheeseburger apparently disclosed in his
recorded statement in Georgia that at
the time that at a previous unreported
White House meeting now this is
important it's at the White House it's
inside the [__] building this is not
a phone call this is not some meeting
that happened at Rudy giuliani's hotel
room where he's tucking his shirt in
down below his balls this is a white
house meeting he breath Trump the guy at
the top of the RICO okay on assembling
fake slates of electors in
Arizona okay now folks this is very
important now how does this important
when Georgia is because Georgia is
charging them with crimes and schemes
all around the country because those
schemes all around the country have to
do with Georgia because they were doing
the same [__] in Georgia that's how the
RICO law Works in Georgia and unfort Ely
for Donald Trump now that Kenneth
cheeseburger here has has pled guilty
and is turned State evidence as they
call it and he's a
rat he in a white house meeting briefed
Trump on fake State electors okay that
is the whole point Cheese's disclosure
shows that Trump was personally
involved in this scheme now I don't know
if anyone else realizes what it means
for Trump to be personally involved in
the fake State elector scheme this is
really bad for a lot of people one of
them in particular being Donald Trump um
he's [__] here he's he's he's [__]
Texas B and the reason why he's [__] I
I don't I don't know if people
understand this like when people go to
turn evidence right and they turn turn
to the state side of a case they can't
just lie they have to provide they have
to provide something of substance so
that the state says yes this is evidence
yes we will trade you this evidence for
your deal right they can't just be like
yeah Donald Trump he he was 100% uh he
had devil horns coming out of his you
know head and even though that's
probably true and I don't want to I
don't want to get that far into it but
they have to understand that there has
to be evidence so so cheeseboro has to
actually prove to prosecutors that yes
he was at the White House yes he did
meet with Trump and yes he did talk
about the fake elector scheme like he
has to prove those things to give this
profer I don't know if people understand
that or not but that's what's happening
and that means that Donald Trump is um
what's the word [__] he's completely
[__]
dear there's just no other way of
putting it when when old cheese bro
flipped man I that's the first thing I
told everybody this is this is big this
is huge because cheese bro wrote
everything down and exactly like you're
saying is when he made that deal he
can't hold a single one of those memos
back because if they find a memo that he
didn't turn over that would talk about
you know oh I don't know I just had a
meeting with uh president Trump at the
White House briefing him on our illegal
scheme which by the way I told everybody
was illegal so he knows it's illegal uh
yeah if he had held that memo his would
have been off the table it would have
mattered if he had finished his entire
testimony and sent Trump to jail if
they'd have found that damn memo he
would have lost his deal and he would
have been sentenced sentenced
appropriately you know I mean it's just
cheese bro is going to be the gift that
just keeps on giving brother well let me
give you let me give you something
better let me give you something better
that dropped yesterday uh this this
footage of Jenna Ellis doing the same
exact thing but it's footage of it and I
believe leak footage is to give uh
trumpers and Maga and the shart Army the
shart Army out there a sense of how
serious this really truly is and how far
this is going to go um because not only
has CH
cheeseboro pleed guilty and done this
proper where he's claiming yes I talked
to Donald Trump directly in the White
House about the fake State electors in
Arizona uh and and not only that Sydney
Powell has met with Donald Trump in the
White House folks in the [__] white
house this is why it is so this is why
this is why Sydney pal is indicted down
there this is why cheeseboro was
indicted down there this is why Jenna
Ellis Rudy Giuliani John Eastman all the
people who met with Donald Trump who
didn't flip on him like Mike Flynn Roger
Stone flipped on him they flipped on him
folks Mike Flynn flipped on Trump he
flipped on him you [__] idiots all
you Mike Flynn people sending Mike Flynn
money thinking he's some kind of hero
for Trump you dumb son of a [__] he
flipped on him he flipped on him he
totally gave away the game for Trump you
[__] oh he pleed the fif say [__] no he
didn't no he didn't he wasn't indicted
he totally 100% flipped on Trump because
this is what it [__] looks like when
you flip on
Trump uh he had come up to me and
introduced me to his family and had said
thank you for the work that you're doing
uh for the president and um I said
something to him like I'm sorry that we
haven't been able to do more and I
emphasized him I thought that the um the
the claims and the ability to challenge
uh the election results was essentially
over because of the dismissal of the
Texas versus Pennsylvania case from the
United States Supreme Court okay so
there she is describing a conversation
she had in the white house with Dan
scavino this is very important Dan
scavino as you know is Donald Trump's
little social media thing or something I
don't know what Dan scavino used to
tweet for him and send out [__] on
through social for him Dan scavino I
think still works for Donald Trump to
this day um but Jenna Ellis is talking
about a conversation she was having with
Dan scavino here so let's let's continue
maybe she gets to the treason part and
he said um to me in a kind of excited
tone well we don't care and we're not
going to leave and I said what do you
mean and he said well the boss meaning
president Trump and everyone understood
the boss um that's what we all called
him okay wait before we get to the
treason bar because she said we're not
going to leave right so that's an
indication that Donald Trump knows that
this is over but he's just going to
refuse to leave but Texas Paul can you
believe that the people out there in
your comments like oh but he Hunter
Biden called Joe Biden the big guy call
him the big guy the big guy the big guy
can can you can you imagine that these
she's sitting there saying we had to
call him
boss yeah yeah I can't I mean because
that's that's exactly if you if you go
back and look at history that's what
Stalin insisted everybody call him when
they talked about Joseph Stalin you
could actually get shot for Joseph
Stalin's name leaving your mouth in the
wrong sentence he insisted everybody
call him the boss and and Donald Trump
is absolutely a Wan toe dictator that
makes total sense that that's that's
what he would want to be I mean I I
would kind of prefer Mr President but
you know that's
me well you you probably would prefer
something other than Mr President but
you know I I'm not GNA say what you'd
prefer or what you wouldn't and what I
would prefer but apparently Donald Trump
preferred boss but let's get to the
treason part because it's there it's
there listen
um he said the boss uh is not going to
leave under any circumstances we are
just going to stay in power and I said
to him well it doesn't quite work that
way you realize and he said we don't
care and you've told us what you knew
the boss to me what did you know we to
mean in that context we I believed um to
mean president Trump uh as the boss and
uh anyone who including Mr scavino who
would have aided him in that effort
which my understanding at the time would
have been uh some of his staff including
uh Mr
Meadows
[Music]
be oh man she did Spill the Beans there
uh on a heavy note she actually said
that dance K said we meaning him and
Trump we and the boss is not under any
circumstances are not going to leave no
matter what and she's like that's not
how it works and he said I don't care I
don't care we don't care we're fascists
that's what it
is yeah um Dan scavino worked for for
Mark Meadows and he was actually around
for the longest he was Deputy white
house chief of staff I think he was
there from the beginning all the way to
the end wasn't he yeah he he is a 100%
died in the wool
loyalist um he he it would be so
freaking awesome to flip him because the
conversations that he and Trump have had
to have been just completely horrific
but that's just who this guy is man and
I am glad to see Jenna Ellis torpedoing
scavino because when you have a list of
people that really need to go to jail
from this scavino is at the top of the
list he really is it's like Donald Trump
and Dan scavino this guy like he said
right there does not give a crap about
democracy doesn't give a crap about the
country it's about him and the boss
that's it that's all that matters it it
that that is 100% true I've got some
speaking of Republican criminals I've
got some breaking news here CNBC has it
here um you're GNA like this this news
Republican criminals here's George
Santos or Anthony deer or whatever the
[__] his name is um representative
George Santos former campaign fundraiser
Samuel me I think is how you say it
plead guilty oh another guilty one son
of a [__] Texas ball it's almost like
it's almost like that's all Republicans
can do nowaday is B guilty and he looks
really sad about it he looks really sad
um so now a fundraiser as blood guilty
in the George Santos case
um m is was accused of pretending to be
the aid for the California Republican
McCarthy so this is the person who was
calling trying to pretend to be the aid
while C listening donations for Santos
for more than a dozen uh would be
contributors uh was he was paid a
commission of 15% of each each
successful donation e you know what that
means that means George Santos is
already [__] but he's [__] even more
in Texas
Paul oh he's [__] even more these are
Republican
criminals yeah I just really you know
people don't understand the machinations
of politics that don't follow this all
the time and I I was really actually
disappointed to see them move on George
Santos when they did people were really
pissed off that a lot of Democrats
didn't vote to remove George Santos and
man it's not how it works there are
safeguards within the legislature just
because you're charged with something
doesn't mean that they will remove you
from Office you have to be convicted
well and that brings that that brings me
to a good point I want and I hate to
stop you there but I've been saying this
to the audience for for months because
they keep throwing this 14 section three
at me with Donald Trump they keep
throwing these court cases that are
failing miserably in these courts it's
going to fail at the Supreme Court and
really no matter what the decision is on
this 14th Amendment um is going to be at
the Supreme Court it's going to be bad
for our country and and it is it's bad
for the institution of democracy to to
just assume someone's innocence before
they they are taken to court um George
Santos has the right to plead not guilty
he has that right he has the right to be
um you know deemed innocent until proven
guilty even though he's we even though
we know he's guilty as [__] based on the
evidence that's out in the Public Square
the law has to treat him as if he's
innocent it's not it's not about the
public now I will say in the politics of
it I am so glad that the Democrats kept
this stupid son of a [__] and I said
for I'm serious I said for months when
he first got in the office we first
found out who Anthony deer George Santos
whatever the [__] his name is was well
kind of out who he was or what lies he
was telling is I said they deserve him
they [__] deserve him he tells lies
like every other Republican tells lies
the only difference is is George Santos
likes all the lies he likes all of them
he likes all the Republican lies so he
tells them
all every [__] Republican is the same
as this jackass right here this exact
same they'll lie to you to take power
and keep their power no matter what no
matter what that's what they'll do and
Frank you go ahead go ahead no Jamie
Rasin just just laid it out perfectly I
mean he voted not to remove George
Santos Santos and he he said it
perfectly he said look I know he's
guilty you know he's we all know he's
guilty we all do but you can't vote to
remove him based on that because that
gives the power to
any da any attorney general any
prosecutor that wants to take somebody
out politically just open a case just
open a case and then your opposition has
the excuse to vote to remove we've got
to have some standards we do and a
conviction is a pretty damn good
standard I mean so I agree with the guy
here's the other thing I'll tell you is
that not only do we have to have
standards we have to have back guards
against this [__] because you may have
scumbags like this speaking of scumbag
Republicans here's James qan on comr
this morning and apparently this is a
good clip I haven't watched it yet but
it's good it's brand new it's hot off
the presses folks and it's got and it's
got Jason and it's got Jason moscowitz
in it so you're gonna [__] love this
one um but here's the thing is that we
can't we can't get rid of our safeguards
to get rid of people like Donald Trump
and George Santos when they haven't been
convicted yet when this guy is
completely wanting to get rid of a
president United States that we the
people elected for for [__] that he did
what [__] that you did that you you're
saying where you took $200,000 from your
brother and you you're and your brother
traded $200,000 you're saying that's an
impeachable offense but yet you did it
um and that's what Jason mosit is going
to challenge him here in this clip uh
but you know this is typical
hypocritical you know it's the hypocrisy
that really pisses you off but you can't
you can't get stuck on the hypocrisy to
try to undermine Democratic institutions
let's see how Jason
moscowitz um actually
defends institutions of democracy but
you and Goldman who is Mr trust fun
continue to try to reclaiming my no I'm
not gonna give you your time back we can
stop the clock you all continue to you
look like a Smurf here just going around
and all this stuff now listen Mr
chairman okay first off first off first
off James comr is way out of his depth
here I mean already when he's attacking
Goldman and he's attacking moscowitz in
this way he is way out in front of his
skis he is totally gonna face PL and
he's gonna be injured by this this is
not going to go well I can already tell
and I haven't even seen this clip and if
comr was a Democrat and Nancy Pelosi was
still speaker of the house he would be
in her office right now getting his ass
torn out because you do not insult other
congressmen you don't bisch their looks
you don't any the house has to function
you can't be calling another Congressman
oh saying another Congressman you look
like a Smurf in the middle of a damn
committee you can do it out in the
parking lot all damn day well apparently
do it in apparently I'm mistaking I
called him I I don't know what I call I
I call I didn't call him Jared though
it's Jared I didn't call him a Smurf
though so you know apparently I said his
name wrong what did I say did I say
Jason did I is that what I said I meant
Jared I thought you said jar that's what
I heard but I thought I I meant Jared
MOS it's
moscowitz just watch this is going to be
great I know it's going to be great
because James comr is it makes an easy
target out of himself and he throws this
rake out just to jump on it you have
hold on if we're not on
time you have gone on TV and said the
president did something ilal you're
doing stuff with your brother American
people have the question why should they
believe why should they believe you
a different rule for the president's a
different rule why should they believe
what you're saying Mr chairman why you
go on Fox News and say loans and deals
are way to evade taxes we don't know
that's what you're doing or not we don't
know we have no idea we're supposed to
take your word for it but when the
president You' already been proven a
liar Mr maritz what's that you've
already been proven a liar who's proven
me a liar you yes your word means
nothing go to my hometown there's a
camera crew there today in opposition
resar search crew there today try Mr
chairman this seems to have gotten under
it seems to have gotten under your skin
I'll pay for your ticket I think the
American people have lots of questions
Mr chairman and perhaps you should sit
maybe for a deposition I will be
happy maybe you should sit for a
deposition yeah he would be happy yeah
let's do that let's have that kind of
fun I'm all for that kind of fun but you
and Goldman who is and I I love how he
says that gold Goldman you and Goldman
oh man I got a camera crew in my
hometown right now to prove that I had
did not blow up that toilet not Denny's
so yeah you know I mean come on give me
a break man give me a break D the other
the other thing that I think is U that
is happening here um is um that comr is
very confused not only about about the
state of his Affairs but the uh the
state of his his impeachment inquiry is
about to get just absolutely acted and
executed um and the reason why is
because he doesn't fully understand the
power of a microphone um here's another
here's another instance it looks like
another instance where he's going to
step on a rake here um let me show you
from this is from just a few moments ago
this is from about five or 10 you look
that up can I can I talk to you about
just how shitty Republicans are at this
just how shitty they are at this do you
know what the loan is about the loan is
about helping his brother avoid taxes
that that's what it's about they all do
it that's why comr did it that's why
comr did it which which are you talking
about Comer's loan or Biden's loan both
both okay this is common a a tax
attorney will structure a loan to a
family member because the family member
a loan is a liability you if I Tony if
you're my family and I loan you if I
loan you
$200,000 on your taxes that is a
liability that does not increase your
net worth okay you can actually deduct
money based on that loan against not not
get additional funds but you can reduce
your liability well you can reduce your
you can adjust your you can you can
lower your adjusted gross because you're
paying taxes on your adjusted gross on
your actual on your form now um what I
what I will say what I will say is the
other thing that uh James comr is going
to walk into here is he's going to walk
into lies watch this here I think I
think this is really gonna hurt him bad
um because I think this is a lie let's
listen and said that it was a shell cuty
because it was an LLC they're so
financially
illiterate that you think because
something says LLC it's a shell
company this company which I financially
disclose has properties never loan my
brother brother
money don't have an LLC oh my God T SP
who's on trial here who's being in pach
here you see do you do you do you see
why I love that Mike Johnson is the
Speaker of House do you see why I love
that James qan comr is out front in this
impeachment battle I love that he's the
chairman of this committee I [__]
love it I I hope I hope that James comr
wins his race and he continues to be the
ranking member in this committee because
Democrats will run laps around the
stupid [__] every single day of the week
and twice on Sunday because this guy is
a [__] idiot I cannot believe that he
let that that he let his Committee
hearing be a [__] deposition that he
has to give let me let me back it up
he's not defending Biden here he's not
defending his evidence against Biden
here in this hearing where he's trying
to imp Beach him listen to what he's
doing and said that it was a shell
company because it was an LLC they're so
financially
illiterate that you think because
something says LLC it's a shell
company this company which I financially
disclose has properties never loan my
brother
money don't have an LLC I wonder if they
were doing 1031 exchanges in a family
from LLC to LLC I don't know if people
know this but you can evade taxes U by
selling and transferring property
um what happens is and I know real
estate really well so what happens is if
you own property a and let's say it's a
commercial property and let's say it's
worth $100,000 to make it easy and your
brother owns a property and it's worth
let's say it's worth $200,000 Texas Paul
your brother owns it but they don't
really own it see what happens is you
get an LLC which some people would call
a shell company because you're creating
a shell that you don't actually own it
that company owns it is what people
normally mean when they say shell
company that's why you would put it in
an LLC but what happens sometimes is
because the 1031 exchange tax code you
cannot trade properties with your family
that is part of the 1031 tax code that
you cannot do um now I'm no accountant
here but what it feels like to me is
they were putting them in LLC and James
Comer and I haven't looked at the deal
but it looks like James comr and his
brothers were doing 1031 exchanges and
they were exchanging properties that
they own um because when you when you
sell a property let's say James comr
sold that $100,000 property for $100,000
to do a 1031 exchange he has to buy
another property he can't actually
possess that money that's why he's
saying I never actually had the money
never actually had the money because an
agent because you'll be taxed on that
money once you receive that money you'll
be taxed on that but if you immediately
roll it into another property you aren't
well and when you to clear that for
people that aren't familiar with these
tax and when you use the 1031 exchange
you're using an agent most of the time
it's a closing agent a lot of times it's
a lawyer sometimes it's a sometimes it
just depends on state to state um but
the 1031 agent actually holds the money
so what James comr could do is sell his
property for $100,000 right and then
what he could do is he could take that
$100,000 put it in a 1031 exchange and
then he could buy his brother's property
that is for
sale for amount of money that could be
disclosed as
$200,000 and then Bango Bango Bongo they
don't have to pay taxes on it then his
brother could then he could buy that
property back or his brother could buy
the property back in another 1031
exchange if it's all in llc's now I'm
not saying that's what happened but um
we'll see here but I I want to play this
again because folks this is a pivotal
point in this impeachment process
because it has gone from Joe Biden is
being impeached to James comr has to
defend his financial his financial
[__] record here listen and said that
it was a shell compy because it was an
LLC C they're so financially
illiterate that you think because
something says LLC it's a shell
company this company which I financially
disclose has properties never loan my
brother
money don't have an
LLC and said
that uh uh oh I don't have an LLC shell
companies have assets right all shell
companies have assets they are almost
all exclusively llc's I mean I don't
know what argument he's trying to make
here it's it's it's it's talk about
illiterate it's an I mean it's an idiot
idiots argument but yeah I mean folks if
you do just a regular old end of the
year here's my 1040 here you know this
stuff is probably you know mind numbing
to you you may not know all these
regulations but I'm telling you folks
they if you attack attorney you get a
tax consult will set up every swap every
everything they can do lower tax
liability it is within the law it's all
legal it is the Republicans than God are
freaking idiots here because what a way
to separate Joe Biden who has a a a man
of the people vibe from the people other
than showing he is taking advantage of
these tax loopholes then that's what
they are but no they they're freaking
morons they're freaking Morant they're
trying to say oh it's a crime it's a
crime it's not a crime it's not a crime
every single person that has any kind of
Assets in their name I assure you if
they've got any kind of assets Beyond
you know one house one car one boat uh
they are utilizing these systems they
really are our tax system needs a
freaking douche man I it really does
people our tax system needs a freaking
douche wealthy people are skipping out
on so much in taxes that they would have
to pay that and they're passing that
liability on to you and it's got to stop
man it's just gotta stop and and comr
thank God mascoit is calling comr out
for being the damn hypocrite that he is
mascoit isn't saying you committed a
crime James comr mosit was saying you
did the exact D exact same damn tax jge
that the president did and you're
sitting here accusing them of things
that aren't true and you know they're
not true because you're doing the exact
same damn thing and then comr turns
around says oh I'm a victim you're
trying to accuse me of having a shell
company you do have a shell company you
jackass you do it's it's to shelter you
shell company is short for shelter it is
a shelter company to shelter you from
tax liability and in criminals cases
legal liability well in other other
other actual liable suits too uh here's
Proverbs gets this totally right never
tried to destroy someone's life with a
lie when yours can be destroyed by the
truth
whoosh
whoo oh my God I'm gonna I'm gonna
[__] screen salute you sir oh my God
hats off so I want I wanna I want to
tell you something that not all not
every single LLC is designed to be a
shell company but almost all shell
companies are in some way sheltered by
some sort of enity that is that is the
thing that that is being uh Mis
misinterpreted here I think um but
speaking of
misinterpretation we got a guy with the
last name
Sanchez oh man just in time just in time
for the Jonathan Carl jinaki clip that
I'm going to [__] go scorched Earth
on here G I don't know how you feel
about this I don't know how Texas feels
I I have mixed I have mixed feelings
I'll talk about it after I'm gonna I'm
gonna get I'm gonna get [__] crazy on
Jonathan Carl here um but because I want
to show this clip because I talked about
it the first 30 minutes and I went off
on him and Jin Saki and honestly I think
it's both of them and it's not just them
but it's them in this clip so I get to
do what I do and I get to attack them
because they're in this clip um because
this stuff is really [__] this
[__] stuff is dumb and it's it's
scummy and we should not be
participating in it we shouldn't be
applauding quote unquote journalists for
this type of stuff so I'm I'm gonna show
you this clip here but Gabe Sanchez what
do you got going on for what was that
live today everyone knows Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday we've got what was
that live right after this show so what
do you got going on over there I'm gonna
talk about this I'm gonna talk about
James com getting triggered inside uh we
just went through yeah we went through
Clips uh I'm going to go
over um there was something else that
was up I'll probably I'll probably talk
about Mike Johnson send me the link by
the way send me so I'm gonna go to this
clip of uh Jonathan Carl and I know a
lot this is gonna piss a lot of people
off because I'm attacking Jonathan Carl
MSNBC and jinaki but I don't give a [__]
it's normal I don't give a [__] so
here's Jonathan Carl and Jin saki
talking about the book I believe this
actually you know what hang on let me
let me actually go back to a different
clip here to make sure I get the correct
one I don't want to [__] this up um I
want to get this right as I'm pissing
off the audience because I'm about to
piss off the audience now you know Tony
Tony sucks Gabe rocks um that's that's
the that's the that's the going the
saying here let me Tony
Su g
[Music]
rock
okay prepare for me to piss off the
[__] audience both rock man I you
both Rock don't blow smoke up his ass
don't blow smoke up his ass Okay let's
listen to a I was talking to you dude
the song says you suck not
him all right let's let's listen to this
you talked to a lot of people and you've
kept in touch with I think a lot of
people who worked for him or worked
around him and another really
fascinating detail in your book is you
mentioned an anonymous former highlevel
official in the Trump White House
somebody close to him you describe it as
who oh he just she he described it as an
anonymous source that okay this is the
thing that really [__] pisses me off
you [__] cowards say who it is tell
us who the [__] it is stop hiding behind
oh I'm trying to sell a book I I could
be sued if I look who gives a [__]
you're a journalist you're a [__]
Journal
journalist the thing that really pisses
me off Gabe Sanchez is Jonathan Carl has
known this [__] for a long long long
time this quote that we're about to hear
from this Anonymous that's still
Anonymous I would prefer that Jonathan
Carl keep this in his pocket and never
tell us about this then to do it this
way if you want to know the honest truth
maybe I'm just an [__] but I'm gonna
be an [__] here because I think that
Jonathan Carl needs to have a little bit
of [__] Thunder thrown his way what
do you think no I mean like this like I
said before I I have mixed feelings one
it's it's good to get it out there right
but two is the same feeling that I've
had towards any one of these people
whether it's you know John Boehner when
he released his Memoir he also did the
audio tapes for as well uh you look at
Bill bar you look at
um uh Bolton you look at any one of
these people who were either in the
Press core or within the White House
Administration during Trump's time or
outside um you look at Bob Woodward you
know these are all people who had access
who who had critical pivotal important
lifethreatening
information and they chose to yeah they
chose to whether it was covid whether it
was military whether it was any number
of things that were out there these
people chose to sit on it and the reason
we the reason being is
because it's not sexy it's it doesn't
sell books on unless you have all of
that story and I know that obviously a
big a big problem are the Publishers
they come to those people or whether
they're approached after the fact and
they say hey would you be willing to
write a story about your experience
during this time and they say oh well
you know I have been keeping notes about
these things that I did not reveal to
the public and then like oh you also
happen to have audio tapes recordings
you you happen to have Anonymous sources
this is where it get I get really pissed
because it's not until a year to a year
and a half after the fact when we could
have acted on it in real time as Texas
Paul said instead we learn about it and
we're like oh well of course that
happened you know we're not [__]
idiots but at the same time it's like
well now we're at a disadvantage because
we let those things play out we let the
terrible situation happened and those
people were like I'm just going to jot
down these notes not going to tell
anybody because I know that this is
going to sell a book
later and it's it's true of Democrats
Republicans whoever but a lot of people
from this Trump Administration are
trying to do this whole I'm rebranding
myself to her with I've got a book
coming out and you won't even imagine
what Trump said in real time well casmo
here um you know I welcome descent on
the show and I'm I'm okay with even
audience members like casmo who is here
every day who's highly engaged
dissenting against me says yes
journalists can't reveal sources don't
be Prim primitive Tony this is not a
source of information this is a personal
opinion that they were giving this isn't
this is not a person who gave a piece of
information that they know it is a
personal opinion that they were giving
of the president of United States in
real time that's not a source of
information that is a quote that is a
personal feeling for someone it is not a
fact or hey this happened this happened
I'm going to show you watch the tape
watch Watch What Happens here shared his
reflection
with you after Trump was indicted he
said quote I'm going to read this
because it's kind of jarring uh he lacks
a any shred of human decency humility or
caring he is morally bankrupt
breathtakingly dishonest lethally
incompetent and stunningly ignorant of
virtually anything related to government
history geography human events or world
affairs he is a traitor and a malignancy
in our nation and represents a clear and
present danger to our democracy and the
rule of law I mean that okay that is
stunning that is jarring and casmo
you're right they do have to protect
their sources the problem is this is not
a source of information this is a
personal feeling that someone told
Jonathan Carl and to be quite honest
with you Jonathan Carl should have
enough [__] Integrity to be sued by
this person by saying hey hey hey hey
hello whoever this [__] highlevel
Trump official is hey this person's
saying this out loud to me in the
[__] white house oh I'm going see you
good sue me [__] good sue me well the
one thing I before I go and I'll let you
guys continue on is that when it comes
to sources right typically a lot of the
time it's like oh this was a source
within this Administration this was a
source from within the military this is
someone who's revealing information as
it's playing out to at least do their
you know and it can be of any industry
too like oh this Insider revealed some
information about the company and now
people want to investigate without
revealing who they are you know we see
it in the GOP when they were bashing
each other you saw it during the most
recent drama filled fight that they had
these are people who either want to save
their position or they are revealing
information that is actually sensitive
and if they reveal who they are then you
know their position but this is again
this is someone who is no longer in that
position they have left the
administration because Trump is no
longer president despite what may
believe and this is not something that's
like oh my God you're revealing
classified sensitive exactly it is
Jonathan Carl holding on to a piece of
information so he can sell a book
because I tweeted this [__] this morning
someone got down in my comments and said
Tony just go buy the book and I'm like
that's the what I'm [__] talking
about that's what I'm [__] talking
about I'm not I'm not knocking the I
mean I am knocking the high level Trump
official that person should have been
out in front of a microphone if they
really felt that way but here's the
thing is Jonathan Carl shouldn't be
profiting up this but you know what Gabe
Sanchez you know what you should do you
know what you should do get the [__] out
of here go do your show what was that
live it's been
fun oh man Gabe Sanchez what was that
live right after this Texas Paul go to
real texas.com Real Texas ball give us
30 seconds give us 30 seconds 30 seconds
your last 30 seconds man I tell you that
was John Kelly I can tell you who it was
the anonymous source was John Kelly he
said it himself he said it himself this
whole [__] you're absolutely right
Tony this is [__] look at look at
Carl's reporting none of it reflects
what he just put in his book that's the
part that pisses me off he knew this he
understood this and this is not what he
told us the American people right [__]
that guy that's that's my problem with
it is you know now that you want to make
money off a book you're G to put this
salacious hook out there that you knew
the entire freaking time and none of
your damn reporting reflects it [__] you
and go to the real go to real the Texas
Paul store trust me real texas.com the
links down below come back here same
time same place tomorrow avilable we
will be there also if if you want to get
if you want to get a great coffee mug
too here's even my cat Ates Ted Cruz
even my dog Ates Ted Cruz grab the
tattoo merch grab a hoodie or t-shirt
whichever you want or go to real
texas.com grab some of his mugs but
right now what you got to grab if you're
on YouTube or twitch is grab your seat
go grab you a piss grab you some water
grab you some coffee and go sit down and
watch what was that live with Gabe
Sanchez same time same place tomorrow
right here on YouTube twitch and
Facebook Surfs Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebor head ass
speaking
that